صراعه عبد الاصابع بين موسكو والغرب يتحول
الى كسر عظام بين الطرفين بعد مذكره
اعتقال من الجنايات الدوليه تنال من زعيم
الكرملين مقامره غير محسوبه قابلت روسيا
حتى الان بالتقليل من شان هذه الخطوه
كونها غير معنيه بمحكمه لا تعترف بها
الرد غير ممكن على جنون الغرب وتصرفهم غير
عقلاني وهذا يعكس مرضهم العقلي المحكمه
الجنائيه لا تعترف بها لاموسكو ولا واشنطن
لذلك مناقشه القرار شيء فارغ
يفتخر بزعيمنا العظيم على العالم ان يعرف
هذا الكثير من الاراء السياسيه في البلاد
تحدثت عن ان اصدار مذكرات الاعتقال تم
توقيتها مع زياره الزعيم الصيني الى موسكو
في العشرين من الشهر الجاري زياره ترى
فيها موسكو خطوه هامه ورساله للغرب حول
ولاده من الخاصره لقطبي جديد في العالم
لن يكون لدينا رئيس هذا شيء مضحك نستنكر
هذا القرار طبعا يا تجنيز لا يمكنني تصور
طبيعات هذا القرار ما يهمني كيف سيكون
المستقبل خاصه مع زياره الرئيس الصيني
وكيف سيتصرف دبلوماسيون حيالها
في تركيبه لولايات المتحده وقرارات
المحكمه باطله ولا معنى لها بالنسبه
لروسيا قرار محكمه لاهارا ومكان الوثيقه
مع محارم المهملات بهذه الطريقه وصفت
موسكو مذكره اعتقالي زعيم الكرملين عبد
الجواد الروشت العربيه موسكو